c'est pourquoi
avoir entrepris ce voyage un peu fou et
prendre pourquoi avoir choisi des
conditions un peu extrêmes qui sont
celles d'un tonneau parce que pourrait
avoir une réponse
alors c'est comme le disait fleurs c'est
un rêve que j'ai réalisé un rêve de
gamin à 14 ans j'avais lu alem embarqué
à lembach des traversées sur
l'atlantique sur un bateau pneumatique
avec une voile il avait mis 65 jours il
ya des traversées sans vivre à bord pour
prouver que la naufragée peut survivre
au milieu de l'océan
et il avait écrit qu une barrique mise à
l'eau au large des canaries mais trois
mois mais trois mois pour arriver aux
caraïbes
et cette phrase m'est toujours resté il
ya une dizaine d'années j'avais remis de
repartir parce que quand ma fille aînée
on est partis s'étant en voilier avec le
bébé ça s'est très très bien passé et là
j'avais envie de repartir d'une manière
un petit peu différente et un matin
cette phrase et elle est revenue à mon
esprit et j'ai dit tiens pourquoi pas un
depuis depuis christophe colomb en 14
193 l'atantique a été traversée à la
rame à la voile en canoë kayak à la nage
en pédalo mais personne jusqu'à présent
n'avait pensé traversée juste comme un
passager un bouchon juste en étant en se
laissant dériver par les vents et les
courants est bon maintenant c'est chose
faite puisque au bout de ce 27 jours en
parfum des canaries j'ai réussi à être
récupérés au large au nord de porto rico
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer plus en détail les préparatifs
de votre aventure
alors comme je voulais dit ça faisait
des années que je mûrissais ce projet
c'est des années que j'avais dessiné ce
tonneau j'étais parti sur la base donc
d'une barrique d'un tonneau et puis j'en
parlais à des amis et en janvier 2018 je
rencontre un copain journalistes qui me
dit vous tenez dans ce projet là de l
écoute je sens un article maintenant il
faut que tu te tu te jette à l'eau tu
peux plus faire marche arrière
je sens un article et puis séparés ces
dates c'est parti donc à mon retour pas
mal de personnes ont dit ouais vous avez
fait un espoir non j'ai pas fait
d'exploit un bon bah oui c'est un espoir
gerbaud et bien autres ce sont des
exploits qu'ils ont fait mais moi
j'étais un simple passager de l'océan
contrairement à mes navigations
présidente au jt capitaine à bord
donc là mais toute une équipe c c'est
comment dirais-je s'est rassemblée
autour de moi et c'est là l'exploit
c'est de d'avoir réussi en même pas deux
mois à monter ce projet un projet qui a
démarré le 5 janvier et le 26 décembre
on largue les amarres
on me larguer à quelques encablures de
l'île de hierro des canaries pour pour
partir à la dérive
pendant donc je vais lire pendant 124
jours
donc c'est là que et c'est grâce à cette
équipe qui a s'étaient tous pour un que
je remercie donc et donc j'ai pu réussir
voilà du coup une fois vous avez été mis
à l'eau est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter un petit peu les quelques
moments forts que vous avez vécu dans ce
magnifique tonneaux alors il faut savoir
que je suis parti dans un premier temps
pendant quatre jours j'avais les alizés
les a divisés le souffle du nord-est
vers le vers le sud est c'est à dire que
je partais des canaries et normalement
je devais me retrouver dans les caraïbes
au niveau à peu près de la martinique
or cette année comment on a une
sécheresse en juin c'est un accès quand
même exceptionnel
et bien cette année ça a été une année
quand je dis cette année oui c'est en
janvier
c'est une année exceptionnelle aussi en
mer puisque après quatre jours de
navigation avec des alizés correct les
alizés ont cessé c'est à dire lieu de
souffler du nord-est 1 se sont mis à
souffler depuis le sud est au lieu de
descendre vers le cap vert
je me suis retrouvé à monter là je me
suis retrouvé à contre courant à
remonter vers les açores donc pendant à
peu près un mois j'étais très inquiet
parce que si j'étais arrivé aux açores
bien ma ma cette traversée vont échouer
et au bout d'un mois j'ai rencontré les
alizés mais j'étais beaucoup trop trop
prononcé pour ça que je me suis retrouvé
à bienne au nord de porto rico
il m'a fallu un mois un mois pour
trouver ces c vent et donc déjà au bout
d'une dizaine de jours je savais que je
ne savais que je ne
je ne mettrai plus je ne mettrai pas
trois mois et j'avais amené 90 jours de
vivres je pensais m'être 80 jours donc
j'ai réparti là je me suis dit là tu es
parti pour quatre voire cinq mois j'ai
réparti le restant de mes vivre c'était
de deux mois et demi de vivre je vais
repartir en 5e cinq parties donc pour
aller jouer au moins pour pouvoir
couvrir à peu près cinq mois ce qui fait
que le 87e jour j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un bateau océanographique
américain
le roi qui passait dans les parages qui
était au courant qu de cette traversée
qui m'ont fait savoir quelques jours
avant que si j'avais besoin de deux
ravitaillements qu'ils étaient prêts à
me i'm a mac os tu es donc ça a été pour
moi un grand moment
c'était le un moment fantastique parce
que j'avais déjà perdu entre 5 et 6 kg
comme je l'avais écrit dans mon journal
de bord si j'avais dû jouer parce que
faire un casting pour jouer gandhi je
pense que j'aurais été pris tout de
suite parce que j'étais assez se
dessécher et là ça a été vraiment un
grand moment parce que 87 jours je
mangeais vraiment peuvent pas grand
chose il faut savoir que les dès que le
temps le permettait je sortais de mon
tonneau j'allais nager pour maintenir
une bonne condition physique en
particulier avec les palmes c'était pour
les jambes pour tous qui étaient les
bras je me faisais des actions common
tonneau d'abord il faisait trois mètres
de long sur 2 mètres d'eau donc je
descendais et quand j'apercevais un
bandeau coryphène évident et que le
temps le permettait évidemment je
partais en chasse derrière elle ce qui
m'a permis à dix reprises de pouvoir
améliorer mon ordinaire abord savoir que
les coûts rifaine
j'ai pu en tirer une après 30 jours de
navigation et que entre la 9e et la 10e
inattendu aussi un mois avant pour en
tirer une donc le poisson je comptais
bout je compte beaucoup sur sur cette
pêche sur la pêche sur la chasse sap a
été tellement fructueux mon nom j'ai
beaucoup de poissons baja danger je me
gavais je me gavais parce que là pour
iphone c'est un poisson qui fait un
mètre de haut qui est assez plat fait
pas 20 kg a fait 5 6 kg donc le premier
jour c'est cet art à recrue évidemment
deuxième jour faste a recuilli troisième
jour ses bougies piles au reste et bien
c'est un appel que je faisait sécher sur
le toit de mon manteau nous et que qui a
quasiment t les pâtes par la suite voilà
ok merci beaucoup jean jacques foos ce
beau témoignage et vous êtes un vrai
marco polo des temps modernes
je trouve est ce que en tant
qu'aventurier vous pourriez donner un
message à transmettre aux gens que vous
écoutez ce que je voudrais que les gens
ça me ferait pas ce que ce que j'en
retire c'est que pendant quatre mois
j'ai pu faire le vide dans ma tête et ça
dans une vie je vois des gens qui sont
tout heureux parce qu'ils sont partis au
ski qui me dise où la parole huit jours
on a décompressé on a fait le vide
ils sont tout heureux et moi pendant
quatre mois je le réussis à faire le
vide dans ma tête
alors c'est pour ça que depuis une
semaine j'ai semaine dernière j'étais en
bretagne chez gérard d'aboville qui a
traversé l'atlantique nord à la rame
voir le pacifique aussi à la rame puis
j'ai été le voir pour qu'il me donne des
conseils et en 2021
vous êtes les premiers à qui je
je l'annoncent en 2021 je veux repartir
je repartirai un tonneau qui fera quatre
mètres qui sera un peu plus long parce
que comme je l'écris même dans mon livre
127 jours à la dérive
j'étais pas pressé au bout de quatre
mois de rencontrer des gens pressés
voilà c'est tout ce que je peux dire là
dessus je pense qu'on peut vous
applaudir pour repartir
c'est beaucoup jean jacques
[Applaudissements]